what does this magi warrior have in
common with this starfleet officer is it
the ability to look really cool the same
actor or both
save the girl
kill the creature
[Music]
yeah it's both the handsome ardith bay
made quite an impression as a part of
the brendan fraser-led mummy movie
series a capable friend to both rick
o'connell and rick's eventual wife
evelyn ardith the chief of the megi
works with them to prevent the mummy
immotep from resurrecting his lover soon
and moon may allah smile upon you always
and
yourself
ardith pops up again and the mummy
returns where he's pressed into service
when a resurrected emotep kidnaps evie
during the second film he develops a
special rapport with jonathan evie's
brother and rick and evie's son alex
by putting this on you have started the
chain reaction that could bring about
the next apocalypse
you lighten up you big trouble you get
in the car ardith doesn't appear in the
mummy tomb of the dragon emperor and was
last seen wishing evie and rick well as
they left egypt for the final time in
returns even if you've managed to miss
him in his recent work the man who
portrayed ardith has still made his mark
on film and television here's what the
man who played the mummy's mystic hero
is up to today
hello
my name is ardeth bay
the first mummy film established odd
fair as an actor to watch and his
subsequent work showed off his range the
same year the mummy was released fair
showed up in the raunchy comedy deuce
bigelow male gigolo he reprised this
role as the debonair charmer antoine in
the movie's 2005 sequel after the
release of the mummy returns fair
appeared for two seasons in the nbc
drama uc undercover as main character
frank donovan he shows up as carlos
oliveira in the 2004 resident evil film
series installment resident evil
apocalypse a rolly reprised in sequel
resident evil retribution he appeared in
the original charm tv series as the
villain of zanku starred in the showtime
series sleeper cell and had a three
episode arc on ncis fair went on to play
the villainous sim nasiri in the 24
revival 24 legacy put in three
appearances as jafar on abc's once upon
a time and he also had a recurring role
on the usa network show covert affairs
as mossad agent ia levine
oh and by the way
if you're looking for this
welcome to join me
in addition to his many appearances on
tv he's also an in-demand voiceover
artist whom you may have heard before in
some surprising places
we can't stay here if the vets succeed
it's the end of everything destiny 2 is
a massive multiplayer game with a rich
sci-fi story that mixes deep floor and
ballistic action in 2017 fair played the
titular character and an expansion pack
to the game titled cursive or cirrus a
job that earned him major brownie points
with his son during an interview with
inquisitor fair revealed that he got a
big boost of encouragement from his son
a major destiny fan while working on the
game the actor explained i have to give
kudos to my son here because my son has
been with me from the beginning with
this he had to promise he would not
share one bit of information with
anybody i cannot even tell you how
difficult it was for him to keep his
mouth shut even though fair sun had to
work hard to keep from spilling any
secrets the actor did share that his
destiny 2 role made him the coolest dad
in the world in another major voice
acting get baer also voiced razel ghoul
for hbo max's animated young justice tv
series
are you proud of this little debacle
i believe the detective would be quite
disappointed
in 2018 he starred in every episode of
hulu's the first to fictionalize the
count of america's first mission to mars
he also appeared as agent levi shure
across four episodes of nbc's the
blacklist and played the villain kareem
peru in the first season of the cbs
series blood and treasure in 2019 most
memorably he was admiral charles vance
on the paramount plus series star trek
discovery cutting a striking figure as
the dashing starfleet officer pair was
also a principal figure in a recent
crossover between three series appearing
as a character colin kent on one episode
each of cbs's fbi fbi most wanted and
the paramount plus spin-off series fbi
international
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]